okay welcome everyone so today we'll be
going over learning theory this is this
used to be taught in the main lectures
and in previous offerings this year
we're going to cover it as as a Friday
section however some of the concepts
here are we're going to be covering
today are important in the sense that
they kind of deepen your understanding
of how machine learning kind of works
and other covers what are the
assumptions that you're making and you
know why do things generalize and and so
forth so here's the agenda for today so
we're going to quickly start off with
framing the learning problem and we'll
go deep into bias-variance tradeoff will
you go we'll spend some time over there
and we look at some other ways where how
you can kind of decompose the error as
an approximation error an estimation
error we will see what empirical risk
minimization is and then we'll spend
some time on uniform convergence and VC
dimensions so let's jump right in
right so d so the assumptions under
which we're going to be operating for
for this lecture and in fact for most of
most of the algorithms that we'll be
covering in this course is that there
are two main assumptions one is that
there exists a data distribution B from
which X Y pairs are sampled so this is
this makes sense in the supervised
learning setting where you're expected
to learn a mapping from X to Y but the
assumption also actually holds more
generally even in the unsupervised
setting case the the main assumption is
that there is a data generating
distribution
and the examples that we have in our
training set and the ones we will be
encountering when we tested are all
coming from the same distribution right
that's that's like the core assumption
without this coming up with any theory
is is it's going to be much harder so
the Assumption here is that you know
there is some kind of a data generating
process and we have a few samples from
that data generating process that
becomes our training set and that's a
finite number you can get an infinite
number of samples from this data
generating process and the examples that
we're going to encounter at test time
are also samples from the same process
that's that's the assumption and there
is a second assumption which is that all
these samples are sample independently
so with these two assumptions we can
imagine learning the process of learning
to look something like this so we have a
set of XY pairs which we call this yes
these are just x1 y1 X M Y M so we have
M samples from from a sample from the
data generating process and we feed this
into a learning algorithm
and the output of the learning algorithm
is what we call as a hypothesis
so hypothesis is is a function which
accepts an input a new input X and makes
a prediction about about Y for that X so
this hypothesis is sometimes also in the
form of theta hat so if we if we
restrict ourselves to a class of
hypotheses for example all possible
logistic regression models of of
dimension n for example then it's you
know obtaining those parameters is
equivalent to obtaining the hypothesis
function itself so a key thing to note
here is that this s is a random variable
this is a random variable this is a
deterministic function
and what happens when you feed a random
variable through a deterministic
function you get a random variable
exactly so so the hypothesis that we get
is also a random variable right so all
random variables have a distribution
associated with them the distribution
associated with the data is the
distribution of capital D this is just
enough ixed deterministic function and
there is a distribution associated with
the with the with the parameters that we
obtain that has a certain distribution
as well in in this in a more statistical
setting we call this an estimator so if
you take some advanced statistics
courses you will call what you will come
across as an estimator here we call it a
learning algorithm right and the
distribution of theta is also called the
sampling distribution and the what's
implied in this process is that there
exists some theta star or in its H star
however you want to view it which is in
the sense or true parameter the true
parameter that we wish to be the output
of the learning algorithm but of course
you know we never know we never know
what theta star is and when what we get
out of the learning algorithm is is
going to be just a sample from a random
a random variable now a thing to notice
that this the theta star or H star is
not random it's just an unknown constant
not about when we say it's not random it
means there is no probability
distribution associated with it it's
just a constant which we don't know that
that's that's the assumption under which
you operate right no let's see what
let's see what what what are some
properties about this theta theta hat so
all the all all the entities that we
estimate are generally decorated with a
hat on top which which indicates that
it's it's something that we estimated
and anything with a star is like you
know the true or the right answer which
we don't have access to in general so
any questions with this so far yeah yeah
so this could be in case of like a
linear or logistic regression linear
regression generally happens to be a
vector it could be a scalar it could be
you know a matrix it could be anything
right it's just an entity that we
estimate and sometimes it's store can
also be so generic that it need not even
be parametrized will it's just some
function that you estimate right so yeah
so it could it could be a vector or a
scalar or a matrix it could be anything
right so let's see what happens when we
so in the lecture we saw this diagram
for India now when we are talking about
bias variance so
in case of regression and we saw that we
saw this as the concepts of underfitting
this is overfit and this is like just
right alright so the concept of
underfitting and overfitting are kind of
closely related to bias and variance so
this is how you would knew it from the
data so this from the data view right
because this is X this is y you know
this is your data and if you look at you
know look at it from a data point of
view these are the kind of different
algorithms that you might get right
however or to get a more formal sense
formal view into what's what's bias and
variance it's more useful to seed from
the parameter view so let's imagine we
have four different learning algorithms
and here this is the parameter space
let's say theta 1 theta 2 let's imagine
you know you have just two parameters
that's easy to visualize theta 1 and
theta 2 all right and this corresponds
to algorithm a algorithm B C and D right
there is there is a true theta star
let's let's which is unknown right now
let's imagine we run through this this
process of sampling M examples running
it through the algorithm obtain a theta
hat right and then we start with a new
sample sample from D running through the
algorithm we get a different data hat
right and the theta hat is going to be
different for different learning
algorithms so so let's imagine first we
we we sample some data that's our
training set run it through algorithm a
and let's say this is the parameter we
got and then we run it through algorithm
B and let's say this is the parameter
with art and through C here and through
D over here and we're going to repeat
this you know second one may be here and
so on and you repeat this process over
and over and over the the key is that
the number of samples per input is M
that is fixed right but we're going to
repeat this process and over and over
and for every time we repeat it we get a
different point over here
right so each point each dot corresponds
to a sample of size M right the number
of points is basically the number of
times we repeated the experiment right
and what we see is that these dots are
basically samples from the sampling
distribution right now the concept of of
bias and variance is kind of visible
over here so if we were to classify this
now we would call this as bias and
variance right so these two are
algorithms that have low bias these two
are have high variance these two have
low where these are low bias high bias
low variance high variance so what does
this mean
so bias is basically checking Rd is the
sampling distribution kind of centered
around the true parameter the true
unknown parameter is it centered around
the true parameter right and variance is
is measuring basically how dispersed the
the sampling distribution is right so so
formally speaking this is bias and
variance and it becomes you know pretty
clear when we see it in the parameter
view instead of in the the data view and
essentially bias and variance are
basically just properties of the first
and second moments of your sampling
distribution so you're asking the first
moment that's the mean is it centered
around the true parameter and you know
the second moment that variance that's
literally variance of the bias-variance
tradeoff yeah
yeah um so this is a diagram where I'm
using only two Thetas just to fit you
know right on a whiteboard so you you
would imagine something that has high
variance for example this one to
probably be of a much much higher
dimension not just two but it would
still be spread out it would still have
like high variance there would be points
in a higher dimensional space you know
but more spread out right so the
question was the question was in over
here we we actually had more number of
Thetas but here with the higher variance
plots we are having the same number of
Thetas so yeah so you could imagine this
to be higher dimensional and also
different algorithms can have different
bias and variance even though they have
the same number of parameters for
example if you had regularization the
variance would come down for example we
go over that a few observations that we
want to make is that as we increase the
size of the data every time we feed and
so if this were to may be made bigger if
we take a bigger sample for every every
time we learn the variance of theta hat
would become small right so if we repeat
the same thing but with larger number of
examples so this would be more all of
these would be more tightly concentrated
right so the spread is so the spread is
a function of how many examples we have
in each in each iteration right so as M
tends to infinity right the variance
tends to zero right if you were to
collect an infinite number of samples
run it through the algorithm you would
get some particular theta hat and if you
were to repeat that with an infinite
number of examples you will always keep
getting the same theta hat now the rate
at which the variance goes goes to zero
as you increase M is you can think of it
as what's also called like the
statistical efficiency it's basically a
measure of how efficient your algorithm
is in squeezing out information from a
given amount of data and if theta hat
tends to theta star as M tends to
infinity you call such algorithms as
consistent so consistent and if the
expected value of your theta hat is
equal to theta star for all M so no
matter how big your sample sizes if you
always end up with a sampling
distribution that's centered around the
true parameter then your estimator is
called an unbiased estimator yes so
efficiency is is basically the rate at
which the variance drops to zero as M
tends to zero so for example you may
have one algorithm which which where the
variance is a function of 1 over m
square another algorithm where the
variance is a function of e to the minus
m you know you you can have the variance
can drive down at different rates
relative to M so that's kind of captures
which what's efficiency here
right yeah yeah so theta theta hat
approaches so this is a random variable
here so so here's one thing to be clear
about here this is a number a constant
and this is a constant but here this is
a random variable right so what we are
saying is that as M tends to infinity
theta hat that is the distribution
converges towards being a constant and
that constant is going to be theta star
which means at smaller values of M your
algorithm might be centered elsewhere
but as you get more and more data your
sampling distribution variance reduces
and also gets centered around the truth
theta star eventually so informally
speaking if your algorithm has high bias
it essentially means no matter how much
data or evidence you provided it kind of
always keeps away from from theta star
right you cannot change its mind no
matter how much data you feed it it's
never going to center itself around
around theta star that's like a high
bias toggle it's biased away from the
true parameter and variance is you can
think of it as your algorithm that's
that's that's kind of highly distracted
by the noise in the data and kind of
easily get swayed away you know far away
depending on the noise in your data so
these algorithms you would call them as
those having high variance because they
can easily get swayed by noise in the
data and as we are seeing here bias and
variance are kind of independent of each
other you can have algorithms that have
you know an independent amount of bias
and variance in them you know there is
there is no correlation between bias and
variance
and one way so the how do we how do we
kind of fight variants so first let's
look at how we can address variants yes
so bias and variance are properties of
the algorithm at a given size M right so
these plots were from well from a fixed
size M and for that fixed size data this
algorithm has high bias low variance
this algorithm has high variance and
high bias and so on yeah yeah you can
you can you can think of it as yeah it
you assume like a fixed data size right
so fighting variance so one way to kind
of address if you are in a high variance
situation this will just increase the
amount of data that you have and that
would naturally just reduce the variance
in your algorithm yes that is true so
you don't know upfront what whether
you're you're you know you know high
bias or high variance scenario one way
to kind of one way to kind of test that
is by looking at your training
performance versus test performance we
go over that arm in fact we're going to
go into you know much more detail in the
main lectures of how do you identify
bias and variance here we're just going
over the concepts of what our bias and
what our variance so one way to address
variances you just get more data right
as you get more data the your sampling
distributions kind of tend to get more
concentrated the other way is what's
called as regularization
so when you when you had regularization
like l2 regularization or l1
regularization what we are effectively
doing is let's say we have an algorithm
with high variance maybe low bias no
bias high variance and you add
regularization right what you end up
with is an algorithm that has maybe a
small bias you increase the bias by
adding regularization but low variance
so if what you care about is your
predictive accuracy you're probably
better off training off high variance to
some bias and getting down reducing your
your variance to a large extent yeah
yeah we'll we are going to look into
that up next
so in order to kind of get a better
understanding of this let's imagine I
think of this as the space of hypothesis
space of right so let's assume there is
a true there exists this hypothesis
let's call it G right which is like the
best possible hypothesis you can think
of by best possible hypothesis I mean if
you were to kind of take this take this
hypothesis and take the expected value
of the loss with respect to the data
generating distribution of across an
infinite amount of data you kind of have
the lowest error with this so this is
enough you know the best possible
hypothesis and then there is this class
of hypotheses let's call this classes H
right so this for example can be the set
of all logistic regression hypotheses or
the set of all SVM's you know so this is
a class of hypotheses and what we what
we end up with when we take a finite
amount of data is some member over here
right so let me call this H star right
there is also some hypothesis in this
class let me call it kind of H star
which is the best in class hypotheses so
within the set of all logistic
regression functions there exist some
you know some model which would give you
the lowest lowest error if you were to
test it on the full data distribution
right the best possible hypothesis may
not be inside
you're inside your hypothesis class it's
just some you know some hypothesis that
that's that's conceptually something
outside the class right now G is the
best possible hypothesis H star is best
in class just in class h h ad is one you
learnt from finite data so we also
introduced some new notation so epsilon
of H is you will call this the risk or
generalization error right and it is
defined to be equal to the expectation
of X Y sample from D so you sample
examples from the data generating
process run it through the hypothesis
check whether it matches with with your
output and if it matches you get a 1 if
it does if it if it doesn't match you
get a 1 if it matches you get a 0 so on
average this is you know roughly
speaking the fraction of all examples on
which you make a mistake and here we are
kind of thinking about this from a
classification point of view to check if
you know the class that your output
matches the true class or not but you
can also extend this to the regression
setting but that's a little harder to
analyze but you know the generalization
holds to the regression setting is
but we'll stick to classification for
now and we have an epsilon hat s of H
and this is called the empirical risk is
the empirical risk or empirical error
and this over here is the difference
here is that here this is like an
infinite process you're you're sampling
from D forever and calculating like the
long-term average whereas this is you
have a finite number that's given to you
and what's the fraction of examples on
which you make you make them an error
right all right before we go further
there was a question of how adding
regularization reduces your variance so
what you can see
actually let me let me get back to that
in a bit so you know G and this is
called the Bayes error so this
essentially means if you take the best
ways possible hypothesis what's the
fraction what's what's the rate at which
you make errors you know and that can be
nonzero right even if you take the best
possible hypothesis ever and that can
still still make some some mistakes and
and this is also called irreducible
error for example if your data
generating process you know spits out
examples where for the same X you have
different Y's in two different examples
then you know no no learning algorithm
can you know
do well in such cases that's just one
one kind of irreducible error they can
be other kinds of identity visible
errors as well and epsilon of H star
epsilon G is called the approximation
error so this essentially means what is
the price that we are paying for
limiting ourselves to some class right
so it's the it's the error between its
it's the difference between the best
possible error that you can get and the
best possible error you can get from H
star right so this is this is an
attribute of the class so what's the
cost you are paying for restricting
yourself to a class and then you have
epsilon of H and minus epsilon of H star
and this you call it the estimation
error the estimation error is given the
data that we got you know the M examples
that we got and we estimated you know
using our estimator some H h H act
what's the what's the what's the error
due to estimation and this is like so
this this the error on G is is the Bayes
error the gap between this error and the
best in class is the approximation error
and the gap between the best in class
and the hypothesis that you end up with
is called the estimation error right and
it's easy to see that H hat is actually
equal to
estimation error plus approximation
error right it's pretty C's with you
know if you just add them up all these
cancel out and you're just left with
epsilon of H hat so it's it's kind of
useful to think about your
generalization error as different
components some error which you just
cannot you know reduce it no matter what
no matter what type odd says you pick no
matter how much of training data you
have there's no way you can get rid of
the irreducible error and then you make
some some decisions about that you're
going to limit yourself to neural
networks or logistic regression or
whatever and thereby you're kind of
defining a class of all possible models
and that has a cost itself and that's
your approximation error and then you
are working with limited data and this
is generally due to data right and with
the limited data that you have and
possibly due to some nuances of your
algorithm you also have an estimation
error I mean we can further see that the
estimation error can be broken down into
estimation variance and the estimation
bias and you can all therefore write
this as and what we commonly call as
bias and variance are you know this we
call it as variance and this we call it
as bias and this is just irreducible so
sometimes you see the bias-variance
decomposition and sometimes you see the
estimation approximation error
decomposition they are somewhat related
they're not exactly the same so the bias
is based
why is you know bias is basically trying
to capture why is a chat far from a from
G right why is it staying away from G
you know why did our hypothesis stay
away from the true hypothesis and that
could be because your classes is kind of
too small or it could be due to other
reasons such as you know as we'll see
maybe regularization that kind of keeps
you away from a certain certain
hypotheses right and the variance is
generally due to it like it's almost
always due to having small data it could
be due to other reasons as well but
these are like two different ways of of
decomposing your your error so now if
you have high bias how do you fight high
bias fight.i bias
so how would you fight high bias any
guesses mm-hmm yeah exactly so one way
is to just you know make your H bigger
I'd make your H bigger and also you can
you can try you know different
algorithms after making your H bigger
and what this generally means is what we
saw there was regularization kind of you
know reduces your your variance by
paying a small cost in bias and over
here you know so let's say your
algorithm has some bias right so it has
a high bias and some variance and you
make H bigger your class bigger right
and this generally results in something
which reduces your bias but also
increases your variance right so with
this picture you can you can also see
you know what's the effect of how does
variance come into picture now just by
having a bigger class there is a higher
probability that the hypothesis that you
estimate can vary a lot right if you
reduce your the space of hypothesis you
may be increasing your bias because you
may be moving away from G but you're
also effectively reducing your variance
right so that's that's the one of the
you know trade-off that you observe that
any step you a step that you take for
example in reducing bias by May
get bigger also makes it possible for
your H hat to land at much
you know at a wider space and increases
your variance and if you take a step to
reducing your variance by maybe making
your your class smaller you may end up
making it smaller by being away from the
end thereby increase your your increase
your bias so when you when you add
regularization you know the the question
of somebody asks before of how does me
in how does adding regularization
decrease the variance by adding
regularization you're effectively kind
of shrinking the class of hypothesis
that you have you start penalizing those
hypotheses whose theta is very is very
large and in a way you're kind of you
know shrinking the class of hypotheses
that you have so if you shrink the class
of hypotheses your your variance is kind
of reduced because you know there's much
smaller wiggles room for your estimator
to place your H hat and you know if you
shrink it by going away from from from G
you you also introduced bias that's like
you know the bias-variance tradeoff any
questions on the so far
yeah you you you probably want to think
of each of these you probably want to
think of this as a generalized version
of this right so here we have like fixed
data on theta 2 but you know because you
could parameterize them into a few
parameters you can kind of plot it in a
matrix space but that's like a more
general like a bag of hypotheses and you
know but in any case in both of both
those diagrams a point here is one
hypotheses a point there is one
hypotheses here it's parameterize here
it's not parametrized yes the thing is D
for D so the question is how what if we
we shrink it towards H star right the
thing is we don't know where H star is
right if we knew it we didn't even need
to learn anything we could just go
straight there right so yeah
with regularization so the question is
when you add regularization are we sure
that the bias is going up no we don't
know and and this is a common scenario
what happens right you when you add
regularization you you you reduce the
variance for sure but you're very likely
going to introduce some bias in that
process
so if you add regularization you're
shrinking your hypothesis space in some
way so you're kind of moving away from
true G so you're kind of adding a little
bit bias you're very likely to add some
bias in that process yeah so it's so I I
would encourage you to you know kind of
after this lecture to think about this a
little more slowly it's it's it's it
takes a while to kind of internalize
this the concept of bias and variance
and and
it's not very intuitive but but you know
thinking about it more definitely helps
all right any other questions before we
move on so an example of a hypothesis
class right so an example would be the
set of all logistic regression models
right and when you do gradient descent
on your you know logistic regression
class you are kind of implicitly
restricting yourself to set up our
possible logistic regression models
that's kind of implicit so the H is the
output of the learning algorithm all
right so you feed an input to your
algorithm this is not the model this is
the learning algorithm like this is like
gradient descent for example right and
the output of that is the parameters
that you learnt that converge to right
so so yeah you probably don't want to
think about this as the model that you
learned but this as the like the
training process and the output of the
training process is a model that you'll
know and that is a point in your in the
class of hypotheses yes so you fix that
the class of learning mods you say I'm
going only going to learn logistic
regression models right for different
different samples of data that you feed
it as your training set you're going to
get learn a different theta hat yes but
they have to be within the class of
hypotheses all right so let's let's move
on
so next we come across this concept
called empirical risk minimization
this the empirical risk minimizer so so
the empirical risk minimizer is a
learning algorithm it is one of those
kind of boxes that we drew it is you
know so in the box that we drew earlier
as learning algorithm right so the the
diagram that we drew earlier based on
which we reasoned everything so far
didn't actually tell you what actually
happens inside it could be doing
gradient descent it could just do
something else it couldn't be you know
some some you know smart programmer
who's written a whole bunch of if else
and just returns a theta it could be
anything right and no matter what kind
of algorithm was used the bias-variance
theory still holds right now we are
going to look at a very specific type of
learning algorithms called the empirical
risk minimizer right so and this was eat
into your algorithm and you get it star
no H its add equal to so what does erm
empirical risk minimization it's what
we've been doing so far in the course
we're we try to find a minimizer in a
class of hypotheses that minimizes the
average training error weight so for
example this is trying to minimize the
training error from a classification
perspective this is kind of minimizing
the or increase in their training
accuracy which is different from what
actually logistic regression did where
we were doing the maximum likelihood or
minimizing the negative log likelihood
it can be shown that losses like the
logistic loss are can be well
approximated by by the ERM and and and
this theory should should hold
nonetheless right so if if we are
limiting ourselves to do that class of
algorithms which which work by
minimizing the training loss right as
opposed to something that say returns a
constant all the time or does something
else if we limit ourselves to empirical
risk minimizer's then we can come up
with more theoretical results for
example uniform convergence which we are
going to look at right now
so so we are limiting ourselves to
empirical risk minimizer's and starting
off uniform convergence so there are two
central questions that we are kind of
interested in so one question is if we
do empirical risk minimization that is
if we just reduce the training loss
right what what does that say about the
generalization error of that so that is
basically the height of H versus H so
for you know consider some hypothesis
right and that gives you some amount of
training error right what does that say
about its generalization error like
that's one central question we want to
consider and the second one is how does
the generalization error of our learned
hypothesis compared to the best possible
generalization error in that class right
note we're you know we're only talking
about a star and not G yeah so it's star
is is the best in class so these are
these are two central questions that we
want to we want to explore and for this
we're going to use two tools right so
one is called the Union bound right
what's the Union bound if we have
see different events - okay then
this need not be independent then the
probability of if this looks trivial it
is trivial it's it's it's probably one
of the axioms in in in your undergrad
probability class the the probability of
any one of these events happening is
less than or equal to the sum of the
probabilities of of each of them
happening right and then we have a
second tool is called the halflings
inequality we're only going to state the
inequality here there is a supplemental
notes on the website that actually
proves the tufting inequality you can go
through that but here we are only going
to state the result in fact throughout
this session you only got a state result
so you're not going to prove anything so
let Z 1 Z 2 Z em be sampled from some
Bernoulli distribution parameter fee and
let's call we had to be average of them
of Zi and let there be a gamma greater
than zero which we call it as the margin
so the huffing inequality basically says
the probability that the absolute
difference between the estimated fee
parameter and the true fee parameter is
greater than some margin can be bounded
by two times the exponential of minus 2
gamma square em not very obvious but you
know you can you can you can show this
what what is basically saying is there
is some there is some some parameter
between 0 & 1 of a Bernoulli
distribution the fact that it is between
0 & 1 means it's it's bounded and and
that's a key requirement for the Hough
dings inequality and now we take samples
from this Bernoulli distribution and the
estimator for this is basically you know
and these are just zeros or ones Zi Zi
each of the Zi is either a 0 or a 1 the
sample a 0 or a 1 with probability P and
the estimator is basically just the
averages of your samples right and the
absolute difference between the
estimated value and the true value the
probability that this difference becomes
greater than some margin gamma is
bounded by this expression so there are
a lot of things happening here so
probably one of slowly think through
this so this is a margin right and this
is like basically like the deviation or
the error
right it's the absolute value of how far
away your estimated value is from from
the true and you would like it to be
closer so you you you probably want your
your fee hat and fee to be not more than
0.001 right so in which case if the
absolute value between the estimated and
a true parameter is greater than 0.001
if that's the margin you're that you're
interested in then this the huffing is
inequality proves that if you were to
repeat this process over and over and
over the number of times fee hat is
going to be great it's going to be
farther than 0.001 from the true
parameter it's going to be less than
this expression which is a function of M
right and that is you can kind of
believe it because as M increases this
becomes smaller which means the
probability of your estimate deviating
more than a certain margin only reduces
as you increase M right so this is
hoppings inequality and we're going to
use this questions
not so so the question is is hate star
the limit of H at as M goes to infinity
it is its star in in the limit as M goes
to infinity if it is a consistent
estimator right so we went over the
concept of consistency I'd given
infinite data will you eventually get to
the right answer and if your estimator
is not consistent then it will it need
not be so in general H hat need not
converge to H star as you get an
infinite amount of data so now we want
to use these tools tool 1 and tool to to
answer our like the central questions
any other questions yeah this is a more
limited version of Hough Kings
inequality and yes if we limit ourselves
to a bernoulli variable
which has some parameter fee and you
take samples from it and you construct
an estimator which is the average of the
of the samples of the zeros and ones
then this inequality holds
that's the this inequality is called the
Hough dings inequality yes
so if you're in general that there are
there there is this class of algorithms
called maximum likelihood algorithms
maximum likelihood estimators and a pure
maximum likelihood estimator is
generally consistent if you include
regularization then it need not be it
need not be consistent though I'm not
very sure about that I'm not very sure
about that so basically you know for the
Mike what he responded was if you have
an algorithm like a neural net which is
which is non convex you may actually not
end up with the same result even if you
increase increase like the number of
though I would probably call the fact I
would probably think of the non
convexity to be part of an estimation
bias because you could in theory always
find like the global minimum of a neural
network is just that there's some bias
in our estimator that we are using
gradient descent and we cannot solve it
okay so now let's let's use these two
tools and for that we're going to start
at this diagram
so over here we have hypothesis here we
have error and
there's actually one one curve which I'm
trying to make it thick and probably
make it to look like multiple curves
this just one curve and this we will
call it s this is the generalization
risk or the
the generalization error of every
possible hypothesis in our class right
so pick one hypothesis that's going to
be somewhere on this axis calculate the
generalization error not the am
particular the generalization error and
you know that's the height of that curve
right and we also have something like
this right so this dotted line now
corresponds to H of H now let's let's
sample a set of M examples and calculate
the empirical error of all our
hypotheses in our class and plot that as
a curve all right any questions on what
these two are yeah it need not beats and
I'm just in fact Li this is very likely
not even a straight line you're just
thinking of all possible hypotheses it
need not be convex this is just to get
some ideas you get better intuitions on
some of these ideas yes so the black
line the thick black line is the
generalization error of all your
hypotheses right and let's say you
sample some some some data right let's
call it s on that sample you have
training error for all possible
hypotheses right we haven't not learnt
anything right it's it's this is the
generalization error and this is the
empirical error for the given s right
now in order to apply halflings
inequality here right so let's consider
some H I right this is some hypotheses
we don't know so we start with some
random hypotheses right and so so by
starting with some hypotheses like think
of this as you start with some parameter
right and so the height of this line up
to the the thick black curve is
basically the generalization error of H
is the height to the thick black curve
so let me call this epsilon of H I right
and the height to the dotted curve until
here and this is epsilon hat of H I I'm
going to ignore the s for now right and
this corresponds to like the the sample
that we obtained now one thing you can
you can you can check is that the
expected value of
where the expectation is with respect to
the data the sample so what this means
is that for one particular sample you
this is the generalization error you got
take another set of M samples that curve
might look some you know some other way
and you know the height of the dotted
line would be there so in general on
average if you Sam average across all
possible training samples that you can
get the the expected value of the height
to the dotted line is going to be the
height to the thick line right that's
that's just a five now here if you apply
halflings inequality you basically get
probability of absolute difference
between the empirical error versus the
generalization error doing greater than
gamma is less than equal to minus two
square this is basically you know opting
in equality we have right here except in
place of fee and fee hat we have the
true generalization error and the
empirical error any questions on this so
far so what we are saying is essentially
the the gap between the generalization
error and the empirical error right
right the gap being greater than some
margin gamma is going to be bounded by
this expression so loosely speaking what
this means is as we increase the size M
if our trainings up if we plot the set
of all dotted lines for a larger M they
are going to be more concentrated around
the black line does that make sense
so so take a moment and think about it
this
dotted line correspond to s of some
particular size M we could take another
sample of you know a fixed set of
examples and that might look something
like this and take another sample of
size M and that might look something
like this
now and now consider the set of all
deviations from from the black line to
every possible dotted line along the
vertical line of H I right now this gap
is greater than some margin gamma with
probability less than this term over
here right so so it essentially means
that if you start plotting dotted lines
with the bigger em right where the set
of all those dotted lines are correspond
to a bigger M they are going to be much
more tightly concentrated around the
true generalization of that of that H
that make sense right you're basically
applying tufting inequality to this gap
over here instead of something that's
basically what you're doing no that's
good but but there's a problem here the
problem here is that we started with
some hypotheses and then averaged across
all possible data that you could sample
but in practice this is useless because
in practice we start with some data and
run the empirical risk minimizer to find
the lowest H for that particular data
right and when you when when which means
that H and the data that you have are
not really independent right you you
chose the H to minimize minimize the
risk for the empirical risk for the
particular data that you are given in
the first place right so to to fix this
what we want to do is basically extend
this result that we got to
account for all H right now if we want
to get a bound on the the gap between
the a probabilistic bound and the gap
between the generalization error and the
empirical error for all age you know
what's that bound going to look like
right and this is basically called
uniform uniform convergence this result
is called uniform convergence because we
are trying to we are trying to see how
the risk curve converges uniformly to
the generalization risk how the
empirical risk curve uniformly converges
to the generalization risk curve and and
it's that that's called uniform
convergence which you can apply to
functions in general but here we are
applying to the risk curves across our
hypotheses and we can show I'm gonna
just skip the math so this we showed
using halflings inequality and you can
apply the Union bound for unioning
across all age except we can first we're
going to limit ourselves to correct so
let me start over so we got this bound
for a fixed edge right but we are
interested in getting the bound for any
possible edge right so that's our next
step right and the way we're going to
going to extend this point wise result
to across all of them is going to look
different for two possible cases one is
a case of finite hypothesis class and
the other case is going to be the case
for infinite hypothesis class so what
does it look like so
so let's first consider finite
hypothesis classes so first we are going
to assume that the class of H has a
finite number of hypotheses the result
by itself is not very useful but it's
going to be like a building block for
further for the other case so let's
assume that the number of hypotheses in
this class is some number K right we can
show that I'm not going to go over the
the derivation but I'm just going to
write out the result it's it's pretty
intuitive so basically what we do is we
apply the Union bound for all K
hypotheses and we end up just
multiplying that by a factor of K all
right so what we get is the probability
that there exists some hypotheses in H
such that the empirical error minus
generalization error this is greater
than gamma is less than equal to K times
K times the probability of any one which
is equal to K times 2 minus 2 gamma
square M and this we flip it over we
negate it and we get the probability
that for all hypotheses in our class
empirical risk - generalization risk is
less than gamma this is going to be
greater than equal to 1 minus 2 K so
with probability at least 1 - you know
this expression which we can call this
Delta with probability at least so much
for all hypotheses our margin is going
to be less than some gamma right this is
this is just
hoppings inequality plus Union bound and
just negate the two sides you get this
and you can go with this slowly you know
later from the notes the notes goes over
this in more detail right now basically
now what we have is no now let's let
Delta K gamma square hmm so we basically
now have a relation between Delta which
is like the probability of error by here
by error I mean that the empirical risk
and the generalization risk are farther
than some some margin and gamma is
called the margin of error and M is your
sample size
so what so what this basically tells is
if your algorithm is the empirical risk
minimizer it could have been any kind of
algorithm but if it is the kind that
minimizes the training error then you
can get by by just changing the sample
size you can get a relation between the
margin of error and the probability of
error and related to the sample size
right so what we can do with this
relation is basically fix any two and
solve for the third and that gives us
you know some actionable results for
example you can fix any two and solve
for the third from this relationship
right and what what what that could mean
is for example so you you can choose any
two and solve for the third am I'm only
going to go over one one one of those so
let's fix fix gamma and Delta to be
greater than 0 and we solve for M and we
get em to be a too many good one over to
gamma square Delta so what this means is
with probability at least 1 minus Delta
which means probably at least 99% 99.9%
for example the probability at least 1
minus Delta the margin of error between
the empirical risk and the true
generalization risk is going to be less
than gamma as long as your training size
is bigger than this expression
all right that's something actionable
for us right now theory can be useful so
this is also called the sample
complexity dessert
right
and basically what this means is as you
increase em and you sample different
sets of data sets your dotted lines are
going to get closer and closer to to the
thick line which means minimizing you're
minimizing on the dotted line will also
get you closer to the generalization
error so this this is basically telling
you how minimizing on on minimizing on
the empirical risk gets you closer to
generalization right okay so that so we
started off with two questions relating
the empirical risk to generalization
risk now let's let's explore the second
question what about the generalization
error of our minimizer with the best
possible in class so let's look at this
diagram again let's say we started with
this dotted curve right and the
minimizer of that would be 8 star and
this is 8 star sorry the diagram is a
little so this is H hat sorry so this is
H at and this has a particular
generalization error right that is the
point of let's assume we got this data
set we ran the empirical risk minimizer
and we obtained this hypothesis and when
we deploy this in the world in the real
world it's error is going to be so much
right now how does this compare to the
performance of the minimizer of the the
best possible
so this is H star best-in-class right
now
we want to get a relation between this
error level and this irrelevant
we got one bound that relates this to
this and now we want something that
relates this to this now how do we do
that it's pretty straightforward so the
generalization error of H hat that's
this dot over here
less than equal to empirical risk of H
hat plus gamma so we got a result using
a huffing and union-bound that the gap
between the dotted line and the the
thick black line is always less than
gamma right and it's the absolute value
so we can we can write it this way as
well and this right so basically we we
started from the thick black line
dropped down to the dotted line and this
is going to be less than the empirical
error of H star plus gamma why is that
because M empirical error the empirical
error of H hat by definition is less
than or equal to the empirical error on
any other hypothesis including the
best-in-class
because this is the training error not
not not the generalization error right
so which means and and this is less than
or equal to so we we dropped from the
generalization to the test and we said
this test is the this training error is
always going to be less than the
empirical error of the best-in-class you
see that the best-in-class was higher
for the trained particular
and this again is now this gap is also
bounded because we prove uniform
convergence that the gap between the
dotted line and thick line is bounded by
gamma for any edge right and this is
therefore H star plus 2 gamma because we
added the extra margin so we wanted a
relation between the the our our
hypothesis generalization error to the
generalization error of the
best-in-class hypothesis so we dropped
from the generalization error to the
empirical error of our hypothesis
related that to the empirical error of
the best-in-class and again bounded by
the gap between these two so we got a
gap between the generalization bound the
generalized error of our hypothesis to
the best-in-class generalization any
questions on this so the result
basically says with probability 1 minus
Delta and for training size M the
generalization error of the hypothesis
from the empirical risk minimizer is
going to be within the best-in-class
generalization error plus 2 times log
Delta so this was basically so you can
get this when you when you so in this
expression if you set this equal to
Delta and solve for gamma you will get
this any questions
I think we are already over time so the
the case for infinite classes is an
extension to this maybe I'll just write
the result so there is a concept called
VC dimension
which is a pretty simple concept but you
know we won't be going over it today VC
dimension basically says what is the so
VC dimension is you can think of it as
trying to assign a size to an infinitely
to it to an infinite size hypothesis
class for a fixed size hypothesis class
we had like you know care to me the size
of the hypothesis so we see of some
hypothesis class it's going to be some
number right some number which which
kind of which is like the size of that
hypothesis it's basically telling you
how how expressive it is and and on
using using the the VC dimension there
are very nice geometrical meanings of VC
dimension you can you can get a bound
similar bound but now it's not for high
it's not for finite classes anymore some
Big O
right
so in place of this margin we ended up
with a different margin that is a
function of the VC dimension and the the
key takeaway from this is that the the
number of data examples that the sample
complexity that you want is generally
you know an order of the VC dimension to
get good results that's basically the
domain result from that right from with
that I guess will will will break for
the day and we'll take more questions